und über die Gemengelage können wir
sprechen mit der verteidigungs- und
Sicherheitsexpertin Claudia Major von
der Stiftung Wissenschaft und Politik
schönen guten Morgen
guten Morgen ja was ist von dem Treffen
zwischen Putin und Erdogan zum
getreideabkommen jetzt heute zu erwarten
es ist unheimlich schwer vorherzusagen
ob es tatsächlich ob es dem türkischen
Präsidenten tatsächlich gelingt Russland
zu überzeugen dieses Abkommen wieder
aufzunehmen wir müssen ganz ehrlich
sagen das Russland in den letzten Nacht
und auch davor ukrainischen Häfen noch
mal angegriffen hat das heißt da scheint
wenig Bereitschaft zu sein für mich ist
noch mal wichtig darauf hinzuweisen dass
es regelmäßig Gesprächskanäle zu
Russland gibt das ist immer wieder
Bemühungen gibt Verhandlungen mit
Russland zu führen aber Russland daran
offensichtlich sehr wenig Interesse hat
sondern immer noch auf sie spielt
schauen wir mal auf das Kriegsgeschehen
von ukrainischer Seite heißt es ja man
habe die erste russische
Verteidigungslinie zumindest in der
Region saporisch ja jetzt durchbrochen
wie bewerten sie das
die Ukraine hat in der Tat in den
letzten Tagen große Fortschritte gemacht
und hat die Initiative in dieser
Offensive wieder und das ist wichtig
weil in den letzten Tagen die kritischen
Stimmen und die Unkenrufe dass die
Offensive gescheitert wäre diese Stimmen
sind immer lauter geworden und jetzt
zeigt es sich dass die Ukraine sowohl
Teile der befestigungsanlagengesetz
zentralen sehr schwierig zu
überwindenden Befestigungsanlagen und
Minenfelder durchbrochen hat und auch
den Druck hinter den russischen Linien
immer weiter erhöht hat also
Logistikanlagen Kommandozentralen
Luftverteidigung und ähnliches
ausgeschaltet hat und das ist in der Tat
ein bemerkenswerter Fortschritt und kann
hoffentlich diese sehr kritischen
Stimmen der letzten Tage beruhigen wenn
die ukrainische Armee will aber jetzt ja
bei ihrer Offensive das 90 km entfernte
als auch schon mehr erreichen und so
dann die russische Besatzung voneinander
trennen sozusagen die verschiedenen
Truppenteile für wie realistisch halten
Sie denn das
was uns der Krieg gezeigt hat seit dem
Beginn des russischen Überfalls im
Februar 22 ist dass das ist voller
Überraschungen ist und deswegen ist es
unheimlich schwer vorherzusagen ob es
klappt was wir aber auch gesehen haben
ist dass die Ukraine viele ihrer Ziele
tatsächlich erreicht hat also ob es
jetzt die Befreiung von Kiew ist von
rechtsonden von krachkies und jetzt auch
der Durchbruch der Durchbruch dieser
unheimlich starken und brutalen
russischen Verteidigungsanlagen und
deswegen wäre ich zuversichtlich dass
die Ukraine das langfristig schaffen
kann wenn und das ist ein ganz wichtiger
Punkt wenn die westlichen Staaten mit
Ihrer Unterstützung im militärischen
Bereich das jetzt Ersatzteile sind ob
das Munition ist ob das weiterreichende
Munition wie Taurus ist dass die
westlichen Staaten mit dieser
militärischen politischen und
finanziellen Unterstützung systematisch
und langfristig weitermachen denn daran
hängt letztlich ob die Ukraine auch sich
durchsetzen kann und den Durchbruch zum
also auch schon mehr schaffen kann haben
sie Taurus schon angesprochen die
Vorsitzende des
bundestagsverteidigungsausschusses stark
Zimmermann von der FDP die hat sich dazu
noch mal zu Wort gemeldet und hat gesagt
diese Taurus Lieferung die ja von der
Ukraine gewünscht werden die würden von
Kanzler Scholz alleine blockiert wie
Kriegs wichtig und entscheiden während
denn Taurus Marschflugkörper aus
Deutschland für die Ukraine jetzt ganz
konkret
also ein Waffensystem alleine
entscheidet den Krieg nicht das haben
wir schon in der Debatte um die
Schützenpanzer und um die Kampfpanzer
und um die Flugzeuge gesehen aber sie
sind ein entscheidendes Instrument um
gerade hinter den russischen Linien so
eine Einrichtung die Kommandozentralen
Logistik aber auch Brücken
beispielsweise zu zerstören und deswegen
sind sie in der Tat sehr wichtig
Frankreich und Großbritannien haben
vergleichbare Munition schon geliefert
also die Briten haben und die Franzosen
Skype geliefert und deswegen kann ich
ehrlich gesagt nicht nachvollziehen
warum Deutschland zögert wenn es
tatsächlich eine sehr wichtige
entscheidende Waffe damit liefern kann
die der Ukraine helfen kann die
Offensive über die wir eben gesprochen
haben vorzusetzen denn es geht noch mal
darum dass die Ukraine die Lage versetzt
wird Druck auf die russischen Linien auf
das auf das Hinterland hinter den
russischen Linien aufzubauen auch den
Druck auf die Krim zu erhöhen und damit
den die Gelegenheit also das Sagen
vorzubereiten dass sie weiter vordringen
kann und dafür wäre es tatsächlich
entscheidend und ich würde mir wünschen
dass die Lieferung hoffentlich bald
erfolgt mittlerweile attackiert die
Ukraine ja auch russische Gebiete
beispielsweise mit Drohnen hat das denn
Auswirkungen auf den Verlauf des Kriegs
diese Angriffe auf russische auf
beispielsweise russische
Luftwaffenstützpunkte oder andere
militärische Einrichtungen sorgen dafür
dass der Krieg tatsächlich auch in
Russland ankommt dass auch Russland
merkt dass es da verwundbar ist und es
schwächt natürlich zumindest mit
Nadelstichen die russischen
militärischen Fähigkeiten und daher ist
es auch wichtig die Ukraine hat
allerdings zugesagt dass sie dafür keine
westlichen Waffen nimmt weil das viele
westliche Unterstützer Staaten kritisch
sehen aber ja diese drohen Angriffe sind
sowohl militärisch als auch
psychologisch sehr wichtige Elemente
sagt die verteidigungs- und
Sicherheitsexpertin Claudia Major von
der Stiftung Wissenschaft und Politik
vielen Dank
sehr gerne